ed a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi
siamo su aim scared che un videogame
indiehorror stai per giocare a hockey
camica anni fermi che cazzo sta
succedendo
prima di cominciare assicurati che nella
cartella dei file che cazzo sta
succedendo sto ancora facendo la [ __ ]
entro un attimo cazzo diceva in scared è
un videogame in d oro degli stessi
creatori di cannes time preventivamente
fracassato le balle in una maniera
incredibile per farlo questo c'è scritto
che bisogna lo so che cazzo ne frega a
me se non avete soddisfatto quanto
richiesto
siete pregati di uscire dal gioco l'ho
fatto l'ho fatto premento stai solo
fatto il gioco sta per cominciare ho
capito porca [ __ ] fatemi iniziare i
tasti vsd saranno premiati nella mia di
gioco tasse serve per interagire donna è
importante un po capodanni fate giocare
un ragazzo l'avrebbe avete bisogno di
sentirselo so porca [ __ ]
scusatemi e scusate mi sto cazzo che
palle allora già possiamo fare non è una
cosa infatti vi è allora un videogame
indiehorror siamo già partiti
siamo già partiti che figo ok va bene
diceva è andato tutto a [ __ ] ragazzi
el intestata litro più bella degli
ultimi 300 video che ho fatto sicuro è
che ho già visto qualcosa sotto il
tavolo siamo neanche partiti
ho raccolto una piccola chiave sono un
[ __ ] genio che fatemi uscire che
tanto ciò la chiave
ho bisogno hai bisogno di un cuore per
aprirla c'è un'altra via infatti mi
sembrava strano ho trovato la chiave
vado per aprire la porta e mi dice hai
bisogno di un cuore per aprirla da
adesso in avanti delle porte si aprono
con i cuori non con le chiavi le chiavi
che usano più un cazzo e la porta è
chiusa a chiave io ho una chiave se
avete intenzione di usarla fate voi se
nome nel filone caprani non lo so
perfetto ma nel file raw neanche a
pranzo evidentemente
ok devo trovare c'è una fessura c'è una
fessura del muro
io speravo ritrovarsi magari una bella
gnocca da sbirciare invece evidentemente
no sei una libreria bellissima io
ragazzi basta tra le chiavi attaccato
così devo trovare a perfetto ecco mi
devo sentire
salve sono un po vj buongiorno è seta
ricavi se mi sa dire chi sto parlando
ti sto parlando dove cazzo vai dove
credi di andare brutto stronzo 5 qua la
gente proprio meschina ma in una maniera
incredibile cioè quando poi nasce più
parlare che la gente si incazza e se ne
va roma comunque torniamo indietro
fottiamo cioè di quel tizio che bel
quadro
devo trovare perfetti che azzolini
credo che la porta l'inizio quella
dell'uscita sia l'uscita finale efficaci
che brutta stanza ragazzi
buongiorno sentano infatti non hai
capito niente di aprire devi aprire fast
anche per lo più la porta è chiusa ok va
bene fa niente
andiamo avanti di qui abbiamo trovato
una chiave arrugginita che mi ha aperto
una porta bellissima tu te la tua chiave
hai raccolto cuore
no mi si è chiuso
no come perché mi sa che sul gioco ciao
ragazze si sono due volte in c'erano
delle cose prima attenzione abbiamo
aspettato il nicchiano una figata
le iniezioni quotidianamente sia il
computer questa entità formata da
semplici byte forse porci e studiare le
nostre azioni e paure di gioco è
semplice mettere i piedi sulle frecce è
la chiave se vieni preso hai perso il
solo le pronuncia all'arrivo e white
face sarre canova beh ma mi si è chiuso
il gioco c'è non so se un bug c'è adesso
morì inizio qualche punto ciao 6 dirvi
qual è il mio nome
while the face white face ok che culo
ok siamo ripartiti credo cosa c'è
scritto giochiamo ha in sé inseguirti
pre gara che cazzo sto sociali ragazzi e
allora facciamo così io me ne dove cazzo
siamo in una cosa io santissimo io ho
preso assoro e tato preso ragazzi
lentamente lentamente è pupa melo tutto
devo riuscire a capire allora calma
eravamo in un parcheggio omissis
mostrato al mouse
ok giochiamo a di seguirti non giochiamo
più un cazzo facciamo un casinò a me si
esce di qua work at raia c'è un piano
piano cosa la sua volta la porta è
chiusa che va allora che a casa aprica
operatore nel parcheggio ok non fa
niente ho paura è che cazzo vuoi la
meglio sto scappando non ora
la bag si continua a trovare il script
la frase ho capito dove p care tutte si
sì ho fatto perché tu qualcosa ho
trovato qualcosa se quello stupratore
che intanto mi segue ma chi se ne fotte
s'è sentito un rumore di una campana
quindi è meglio che che si sblocchi si
si si si aprì la cena veloce ma siamo
già arrivati non potevo stare un
pochettino di più sinceramente a me non
andava male a questa dove siamo adesso
cos'è una strada ma mi vesto mi avete
rotto le palle
ok adoro guardarti ma che cazzo è un
maniaco se vuoi ti do un paio di mie
foto ti guardi quella e non rom piccoli
cos'è uno di loro mente o te ho capito
adesso penso al nata di merda ma non
importa ho trovato una chiave del
cancello quindi magari sappiamo soffro
taci tu a fare quello che vuoi o tesi
apertosi aperto se partisse parto si
aperto si aperto dove esattamente cazzo
siamo ragazzi non sto capendo dove
stiamo andando ma c'è una porta assieme
dall'altro diretta a mano ok ok ok ci
sono mi sono ritrovato perfetto posso
uscire perché avevo trovato il cuore
prima poi mi avevate trasportate quindi
non potevo più tornare indietro il suo
posto a pretty via fuori dalle balle che
fin fine ho vinto mi sembra troppo
strano però va bene quindi è finito
ragazzi io non so che cazzo è successo
ma si è bloccato qui quindi devo premere
mica esca ragazzi porca [ __ ]
è il mio desktop quel che succede
ragazzi mi sia per tosta cosa su google
e non è una cosa normale facciamo finta
mi dispiace ti dispiace cosa non ha
intenzione di lasciarti andare non avrei
dovuto spronati ad andare avanti
prendi tempo in cerca di uscire ma cos'è
che ho preso lentamente po povero tutto
non ho scritto io ma se lo abbiamo far
iniziare vero però che fosse finito ma
non angel ha scritto film che ha scritto
fino al meno farmi soffrire in silenzio
trovato un'altra chiave chiave 1 ok la
porta numero uno la si apre perfetto i
ragazzi pensavo pensa speravo fosse
finito ma non è finito e non fa niente
devo andare devo andare ci porta
non volevo farlo cosa non va devi farlo
calmo calmissimo ok go ha detto di stare
car maniaco che cazzo tipi che covo e
aspetti che mi deludi vero perché se un
maniaco facciamo figlio faccio finta di
non averti visto tu non mi paghi il
cazzo ok perfetto ancora ancora ma basta
io magari vado accesso mi sa che mi
tocca a uscire senti maniaco ok ok non
stavo scherzando stavo scherzando di
idee fatemi entrare dalla finestra alice
del sangue la cosa non mi piace ragazzi
stessi giostrine di merda cioè una
chiave di anche magari se si apre
qualcosa mi fa anche piacere
cos'è la chiave 7 è diventato giorno lì
però sono andato in paradiso è diventato
giorno non lo so che una volta 7 velocci
gatti sta diventando veramente orribile
la faccenda per ta 7 questa è la mia
stanza e vedi come buio e guarda siamo
in due
ok beh fa freddo no no no no no
scherzavo scherzano mica mi sto pagando
addosso già si spengo la luce ma posso
guardarti hai paura e se io ti finanzi
questa ne culo aspettate fermi perdita è
ok che su ragazzi sta succedendo di
tutto non sono anche cappello magnola
portato perfetto ed accolto la chiave 6
apriti perfe cosa mi dice che non era
così prima che caso sono tornati exit
loro che buio ragazzi e buu e troppo e
troppo buio non vedo un cazzo ma
ripensandoci torno anche indietro
ragazzino trovo più dove dovrò ok vabbè
senta e lì ho trovato questo posto
perché congratulazioni grazie a un e ho
vinto adesso
posso andare se giunta alla fine si
grazie grazie mille allora possiamo
finirla qui ma da qui non puoi uscire
porca [ __ ] rimani con me no devo
vedere breaking bad fini non può io
rimarrò sempre qui
vabbè se c'hai la tv guardiamo insieme
non lo so guardandoti cazzo di
stupratore sa benissimo ragazzi fuori
dalle palle a un ascoltami maniaco
person g vedenti sani non si aspetta vai
domani è comunque non è sì posso proprio
entrarti nella testa bello
sei molto sexy non so se aggiunto
nessuno tra maglietta comune mi sono
rifugiato mi sono impegnato non l'ho
fatto apposta ma non importa a di adire
sono grazie mille sei gentilissimo 0
punto tv si è vivo che cosa concreto
scusatemi scusatemi davvero non potevo
fare altro paura non voglio dormire
d'ora in avanti ricordate sono ne
preannuncia l'arrivo mi dispiace e sti
cazzi ragazzi è stata una cosa che non
ho parole tra l'altro c'è la mia webcam
bellissima e dopo questa cosa qui direi
che si può mettere una canzone è carina
beh ragazzi prima che mi arrestino per
capirai che facciamo che ci vediamo al
prossimo vito perché non è chi capito
che a caso successo comunque davydov è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato
argomento mi piace anche a base di
facebook come in ogni video tratto nella
descrizione seles e da chris chiti
iscrivetevi ci rivediamo un persino
vinto bene ragazzi